joe biden admits that his eviction
moratorium is unconstitutional but
hey what the hell plus biden attacks
florida governor ron desantis who
absolutely clocks him
i'm bench bureau this is the bench
bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with vpn so should you
visit expressvpn.com
then we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first here is your reminder
that the government is spending money
that they do not have and that means
eventually they're going to have to
either raise taxes or
raise the amount of money that they are
printing and when that happens you are
going to want to have your assets at
least a little bit diversified away from
stocks
and bonds and into something like birch
gold
in their recent budget proposal the
white house budget office forecast
inflation for 2021
at 2.1 percent in june the actual
inflation rate was 5.4
inflation is already here and now you
have people from the federal reserve
saying that it's going to last longer
than they originally thought it would
that is not a shock if you haven't
reached out to birch gold to diversify
part of your ira or 401k into a precious
metals ira
do it today tech spends 47 47 47 get a
free information kit on protecting your
savings
with gold i buy my gold from birch gold
have an a plus rating with the better
business bureau countless five-star
reviews thousands of happy customers
give them a call right now have them
help you safeguard
your retirement savings text ban to 47
47 47 claim your free no obligation info
kit
speak with the precious metals expert on
holding gold and silver in a tax
sheltered account again
text my name ben to 47 47 47
protect your savings today okay we're
gonna get to everything coveted related
in just one moment first here's your
andrew cuomo update
there's no update nothing has happened
just i i just want you to recall for a
second that andrew cuomo
it was known last year had killed
basically all the old people in new york
and then covered it up and the reason i
laugh is because you sort of have to
laugh when somebody is this blatant
about it and get a
gets away with it and the entire media
just continues to massage him
and then it turns out there's this big
scandal because he's been sexually
harassing the help
whether it's on his campaign or in his
campaign offices or whether it's in his
gubernatorial office has been doing this
for years on end
and at the time that all of this was
reported there was talk about well maybe
we should do something about it well now
there's been this report from leticia
james like 168 pages
and this 168 page report is just replete
with andrew cuomo not being able to keep
his hands off the hired help and it
really is an incredible incredible thing
the report is very long it talks about
how he's groping people and how he's
touching people in an uncomfortable way
and how he is then threatening their
jobs if they don't
sort of reciprocate his feelings and all
the rest of this and remember
andrew cuomo's response to these charges
after leticia james the attorney general
of new york came out with all this
his response to all of this was well you
know i do touch a lot of people
i'm not kidding right here just just so
you recall
here was andrew cuomo's little slideshow
that he did the other day trying to
excuse
him grabbing women by the boobs and such
indeed there are hundreds if not
thousands of photos of
me using the exact same gesture
i do it with everyone black and white
young and old
straight in lgbtq
powerful people
friends strangers
people who i meet on the street i mean i
do love that defense which is like
look here's a bunch of pictures of me
hanging out with robert de niro and
giving him the old
double cheek grab and here is me with
with al gore giving him a little peck on
the cheek that is exactly the same as
that time that i stuffed my hands up a
woman's blouse and tried to grab her
boobs
exactly like what the hell is wrong with
you
what seriously this is like lenny from
of mice and men
using as his defense to strangling a
woman's death that he also likes to pet
bunnies no these are not related things
that no that is not a defense dude
i mean the fact that you're like
grabbing charlie rangel by the back of
the neck
al pacino style and the godfather too
like that that does not have anything to
say about whether you are grabbing state
troopers
by the by the belly and and like
massaging them and such
it's just an incredible thing but this
guy's going to get away with it
understand he's going to get away with
it because the democrats are not going
to impeach him
and this does give the lie to the whole
democrats
saying for years on end well these
republicans they have no standards let's
be real about this
no one has had standards since bill
clinton okay the democrats had the
opportunity to get rid of bill clinton
over this exact sort of stuff in the
late 90s they decided that his agenda
which by the way would have been carried
on by al gore but his agenda
was more important than standing up for
the principal and so they decided to let
bill clinton survive
and now every politician knows that if
you just wait it out long enough it'll
be fine
and and you can see it happening in real
time so yesterday for example joe biden
called for andrew cuomo
to resign of course if andrew cuomo says
no
he has no actual repercussions in store
here is joe biden calling for coleman
resign the other day
back in march you said that if the
investigation confirmed the allegations
against governor cuomo
then he should resign so will you now
call on him to resign given the
investigators said the 11 women
were credible i stand by the statement
are you now calling on him to resign yes
and if he doesn't resign do you believe
he should be impeached and removed from
office
let's take one thing at a time here i
think you should resign
i love that response right there we'll
get to it when we get to it guys i mean
the actual serious question is to like
what will you do if he just doesn't
leave he's like well you know
well here's the thing we do know we do
no because ralph northam
you'll recall was also asked resigned by
nearly all the democrats when it turned
out that 35 years ago
he dressed in a medical school yearbook
in either blackface or a kkk outfit
and you'll remember that everybody said
he needs to go and then there was talk
about justin fairfax his lieutenant
governor
who'd been accused of sexual misconduct
and people were like well
maybe he has to go both of them are
still in office
you can just live it out right everybody
knows you can just live it out right jen
saki pretty makes
she makes this clear i i do also love
jen saki's response so she was asked
specifically
you know you said that there should be
an independent commission to investigate
the allegations about andrew cuomo
you until i can in like an independent
commission for you know like tara reid
and joe biden you know the allegations
against joe biden that he sexually
harassed somebody
back in the 1990s and and she's like nah
not so much
yeah we know we know okay we all know
should there be an independent
investigation of allegations into the
president as there was into governor
fomo
well first i would say the president has
been clear and outspoken about the
importance of women
being respected and having their voices
heard and being allowed to tell their
stories
and people treating them with respect
that has long been his policy continues
to be his policy
that those were that was heavily
litigated during the campaign
i understand you're eager to come back
to it uh but i don't have anything
further other than to repeat that he has
called for
uh videos litigation we're done here
we're done here guys now meanwhile bill
de blasio
is really out there because one of my
favorite things in politics is the
absolute utter hatred between bill de
blasio and andrew cuomo
these two ridiculous narcissists despise
one another de blasio hates cuomo
cuomo hates de blasio both have
excellent reason to hate each other
because they're both extremely hateable
bill de blasio does not pull any punches
he's like not only should cuomo resign
cuomo should be criminally charged and
uh you know when andrew cuomo says that
it's a generational thing how he talks
to people
and how he touches people bill de
blasio's like you know when you stick
your hands up somebody's shirt that's
not really generational
points to bill de blasio that weird old
communist
the whole thing has been so painful when
you read this report
11 women systematically wronged
11 women affronted by a powerful guy who
could
crush their career and their reputation
and he's the kind of guy everyone
assumes would
if you crossed him putting your hand up
a woman's shirt and touching their
breast is not generational
i know plenty of guys who are older who
would never in a million years do that
uh bill de blasio makes a good point i
know that that is a sentence that has
never left my lips before nor will it
ever
again in all likelihood but his point is
well taken
final point with regard to andrew cuomo
before we move on
it is incredible that chris cuomo is
going to retain his job at cnn it is
just unbelievable he spent all of last
year
talking up his brother's response to
covid which again
new york has the second worth worst
death per million
ratio in the nation it goes new jersey
and then new york okay and
chris spent every waking moment talking
up how wonderful
his brother was listen i get he's your
brother i do really i do
but if you're gonna pretend to be an
objective journalist you don't get to do
that
so he talked up his brother's coveted
response he then was advising his
brother he was writing his brother's
press releases and all the sexual
harassment stuff
so last night he had the ability to
cover andrew on
air and of course what did he do he just
ignored the story completely it was only
the biggest story in the country
yesterday he just ignored it
i'm chris cuomo welcome to prime time
we're focused on covid here
especially until we get the delta
variant under control and for now
as you know it's getting worse okay so
what does all this
really mean in the end it just means
that there are no norms when people say
that norms are violated that republicans
break norms democrats break norms
here is the thing there are no more
norms
okay the norms have largely been
discarded and this is why people don't
trust
the institutions this is why the
institutions are falling apart
and when you hear people on the left
claim that authoritarianism is around
the corner because of president trump
who violated all the norms
let's be real about this once again
trump was the coroner he was not the
murderer the norms were already dead
trump just declared them dead trump just
came along and he said
yes you're right this body is cold this
corpse has been here for a while
the the norms in american politics have
basically been discarded they've been
gone for quite a while
and now it's just a matter of declaring
them gone and the democrats are not
being too shy about any of that
today's case in point is joe biden so
joe biden
is engaging right now in some pretty
authoritarian
stuff now if donald trump had come along
and said listen i'm about to do
something i openly acknowledge is
unconstitutional now watch me
people would have lost their minds right
they would have said that that's that's
pretty insane
is it not i mean and by the way trump
did say
wild stuff while he was president that
was authoritarian talk
i think that when he was rejecting the
results of elections that is not the
kind of talk you want out of the
president of the united states
but joe biden was supposed to be the
restorer of norms he was supposed to be
the return of captain normalcy right he
was
the moderate guy in the room he was not
going to violate
constitutional norms well just like his
predecessor
in the democratic party barack obama he
has now said
that he is just going to acknowledge
openly that things are unconstitutional
and then do them
anyway so you'll recall that barack
obama said over and over and over again
that he could not from the executive
office simply declare amnesty
for the so-called dreamers he said it
dozens of times
and then he was like well maybe i'll
just do it anyway well now
joe biden is doing the exact same thing
with regard to a new
cdc moratorium on evictions all right so
biden had been talking about the
possibility of a brand new
cdc eviction moratorium now recall
the cdc has no statutory power to simply
determine that landlords all over the
united states
have to forfeit their rents okay this
does not exist
anywhere in american law it is an
absurdity on its face
but the cdc has been pushing it for a
year like
over a year at this point the supreme
court
took this up and they said it's pretty
obvious the cdc doesn't have this
authority and we would strike it down
but it appears that this thing is going
to be moods because in a couple of weeks
it sort of just goes by the wayside
right it expires on july 31st
and so at that point congress can take
it up anew but if the cdc does it anew
then we are going to say that it's
unconstitutional right there's a 5-4
decision in which justice kavanaugh
wrote the decision okay well now joe
biden is saying
openly without a doubt he's just saying
it straight up
that the cdc does not have the power to
declare a new moratorium
but he is going to push them to do it
anyway right he said this yesterday it's
an insane statement
it is a dictatorial statement it's it is
full authoritarian
when the president of the united states
openly says i have no authority to do x
now i'm going to try and do x that is
the definition of somebody who does not
give a damn about the constitution of
the united states
joe biden by the way does this kind of
stuff routinely right he's constantly
saying
i don't think i have the power to do
that from the executive office and then
he's pushed by his left flank and
suddenly
he seems to reconsider so on tuesday
biden announced that the cdc would push
for a new moratorium on evictions
before admitting that the order was
quote unquote not likely to pass
constitutional muster
here is biden fully again admitting he
doesn't have the authority to do this
while pushing the cdc to do it
whether that option will pass
constitutional measure with this
administration
i can't tell you i don't know
there are a few scholars who say will
and others who say it's not likely to
but at a minimum by the time it gets
litigated
we'll probably give some additional time
while we're getting that 45 billion
dollars out to people
who are in fact behind in the rent and
don't have the money okay so what he's
openly saying right now is i'm going to
do an unconstitutional thing
i know it's going to get struck down by
the court but because it takes the
court's
time to litigate that measure that is
going to give me additional time to do
all these other things i need to do
that's about as openly cynical a move as
i've ever seen in american politics
that's not democracy dying secretly
that's not democracy dying in darkness
that's democracy dying just right in
front of you to the cheering
of the media by the way wait until you
hear some of the headlines
okay i mean biden himself says quote the
bulk of the constitutional scholarship
says it's not likely to pass
constitutional muster
but there are several key scholars who
think that it may who by the way did he
actually talk to lawrence tribe
of harvard law school who became an
absolute joke over the course of the
trump administration
when he just started saying crazy things
over and over
and over again by the way all of this
followed hard
on corey bush so cory bush is the the
the congresswoman from missouri a black
lives matter activist you somehow
join adjunct member of the squad
sleeping on the steps
of the capitol building to demonstrate
what it's like to be homeless wow what
such such heroics such a such imagery
and this apparently prompted
biden to make his move here the cdc
statement here by the way is insane
you know there are actual fines that are
associated with this the actual fines
include for example a 100
up to a 100 000 fine for evicting
somebody
okay i like i don't understand where the
cdc gets this authority i really don't
how under under what auspices
like punishing people with with a
hundred thousand dollar fines
how it's but apparently
those are the criminal penalties i'm
reading from the cdc order right now
under 18 us code 3559
a person violating this order may be
subject to a fine of no more than a
hundred thousand dollars or one year in
jail or both
if the violation does not result in a
death or a fine of no more than 250 000
or one year in jail or both if the
violation results in a death as
otherwise
or as otherwise provided by law an
organization
violating this order may be subject to a
fine of no more than two hundred
thousand dollars per event
if the violation does not result in a
death or a half million dollars per
event
if the violation results in a death i
don't know what it means for it to
result in a death so
what happens you evict somebody and then
they can't find a place that they want
to rent
and then they just die like what does
that actually mean
is the little match girl out on the
street what are we talking about here
but
bottom line here is it really doesn't
matter the bigger story here is that the
cdc is just doing openly
unconstitutional things the app is best
and apparently nobody seems to give a
hot damn for even a second
and then the norms crowd is going to
lecture us then we're going to get
lectures from the norms crowd about
republicans
and how republicans violate norms and
how republicans are the true
authoritarians really
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about a simple
fact
when you are at the office you are
sitting on an office chair much of the
day that office chair is likely giving
you back pain it's giving you hip pain
what you need is the greatest of all
office chairs i of course i'm talking
about the x chair
it's like direct from god the extra the
extra can give you a massage while
you're sitting at your desk
it can warm your back on cold mornings
it can cool you off on hot days
lmx temperature regulation will take
your seating comfort to a whole new
level
patent-pending lmx allows you to
experience cooling heat and massage in
your low back
extra's patented dynamic variable lumbar
support was already best in class with
incredible responsive low back support
now
with lmx your comfort is guaranteed you
won't believe the difference until you
feel it for yourself
and just tell you that the extra in our
offices we've got our producers
basically
in pitch battles with one another over
who gets to sit in the magnificent ex
chair go to exchairshapiro.com right now
that is the letter x
chair shapiro dot com or call one eight
four four
four x chair for a hundred bucks off
your order extra has a 30 day guarantee
of complete comfort
you can finance your purchase for as
little as 30 bucks a month go to
xchairshapiro.com right now
use code x wheels for free x-wheel blade
casters that's
x shapiro.com once more xchair
shapiro.com
right now use code x-wheels for free
x-wheel blade
casters as well and again there's all
sorts of other deals when you call eight
one eight four four
four x chair or visit xchairshapiro.com
right this very minute and you should
get the chair anyway because it's just
fantastic okay so
jen's hockey basically admits this she's
like yeah you know it might be
unconstitutional but here's the thing no
one cares
what's the white house's message then to
americans who heard what happened
yesterday
heard what was said at this podium on
monday can't square the two and are now
disappointed
that the president is signaling that he
doesn't respect the rule of law
i'm not sure there are americans
evaluating it to that degree maybe there
are some you've talked to i don't know
what the president has his message to
the american people especially those
who are concerned about losing their
homes being kicked out of their homes is
that he's going to do everything in his
power
to make sure they can stay in their
homes that's the whole thing
that's the whole thing so long as he
signals that he is willing to do
something
even if something he is doing is
authoritarian and violates all the rules
that's all that matters in the end
because as i've been discussing
the past several weeks americans at this
point have a bias toward action
even if that means violating all of the
rules which is a really scary
precondition to actual authoritarian
dictatorship
this is what authoritarians do
authoritarians say i can't get it done
using the using the complex system i've
been given with the checks and the
balances in the legislature and all this
so i'm just going to do what you the
people
want the people yes that's my bane voice
from dark knight rises because that's
what this is right they're handing power
back to you
the people that's all that matters so
long as you are fine with him violating
the constitution
the constitutional violation poof it
just doesn't matter
anymore at all and the media celebrate
this kind of stuff democracy dies in
darkness
the washington post here was their
headline from the fix this is aaron
blake
biden's novel evictions defense maybe
it's illegal but it's worth it
yeah we we noticed we noticed maybe it's
illegal but it's worth it as a hell of a
statement for presidents of the united
states to be making
and for the washington post to be
quasi-celebrating
early last decade then president barack
obama and congress were in a standoff
says aaron blake obama
badly wanted congress to pass long
failed comprehensive immigration reform
but allies called for him to do
something himself
his repeated response i can't i'm not a
king i'm not an emperor
the old constitutional law professor
wanted to force congress to do things
the old-fashioned
more robust ways but when congress
continued to stall he did something
himself anyway
twice the lessons of this apparently
weren't learned by his vp
joe biden and biden's new administration
or if they were the lesson was
apparently
that it was a gambit worth repeating
it's a heck of a way to do the country's
business
and biden arguably took it even further
than obama did
the previous moratorium on evictions had
lapsed a few days previously the
administration wanted congress to do
something about it
they had good reason it appeared
congress had to do something because the
supreme court had already ruled
on all of this but now because the cdc
points to the delta variants
now they get to say that they are going
to extend the moratorium by the way
again it is dictatorial stuff
that the cdc was able to extend
moratoria in the first place
that's nuts why exactly does the cdc get
to say in the middle of us
blowing money out the door no like no
time in human history seriously no time
in human
you understand last year americans ended
the year on average with more savings
than they had
at the beginning of the year in the
middle of a pandemic the one group of
people who got absolutely jacked
were the people who owned the buildings
now the best part of all of this of
course
is going to be the unintended
consequence because it turns out
when you tell developers and landowners
they can't collect rent you know what
they stop doing
building homes so when there is a
housing shortage and when the prices
continue to rise
when there's an apartment shortage and
there's and prices continue to rise you
know what the left will say
they'll blame capitalism they will have
created
the shortage and then they will blame
capitalism the beautiful thing about
being
a member of the left is being a leftist
means never having to say you're sorry
you can completely wreck all of the
incentives and still
blame the other guy it's really
impressive by the way cnn
was doing the same thing as the
washington post stephen collison at cnn
has a headline says biden shows he's
ready to make drastic moves in kova 19
fight
even if he's not sure they're legal well
i mean that is a very different headline
i feel
than it would have been if if for
example donald trump had openly said it
was unconstitutional and then done it
i have a feeling it wouldn't have been
about how willing he was to help the
american people
i have a feeling you would have been a
lot more upset with the violation of
norms the dictatorial
violation of norms but again
it only counts as a dictatorial
violation of norms when the press
opposes your party if the press is in
favor of your party
then it's just you being so brave so
unbelievably brave in the face of the
evil constitution of the united states
alrighty in just one second we're going
to get we're going to talk about the
latest emergency talk surrounding covet
and the
pitched battle that is broken out
between joe biden and governor ron
desantis of my home state
of florida first let's talk about the
simple fact that if you ever get into
credit card debt it is a serious problem
you want to wreck your life getting into
credit card debt is an excellent way to
do it i know people
really who've destroyed marriages i know
people who have destroyed their
livelihoods because they've gotten into
credit card debt they start racking up
those giant interest fees
and now they're really behind the eight
bulb well if you're like most of us you
do need to carry a balance on your
credit cards
if those cards come with high interest
rates you need to talk to my friends
over a light stream you can lower your
interest rate and save with a credit
card consolidation loan from light
stream
rates start at 5.93 apr with auto pay
and excellent credit
lightstream believes that people with
good credit deserve a better loan
experience that's exactly what they
deliver
you can get a loan from five thousand to
a hundred thousand dollars there are
absolutely no fees
you can even get your money as soon as
the day you apply just for my listeners
right now you can apply to get a special
interest rate discount and save even
more the only way to get that discount
head on over to lightstream.com shapiro
that's l-i-g-h-t
s-t-r-e-a-m.com shapiro subject for
credit approval
rates range from 5.93 apr to 19.99
apr and include 0.50 auto pay discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply officer
subject to change without notice visit
lightstream.com
shapiro for more information alrighty so
meanwhile
the the continued push for panic it just
it never ends
it never ends from our from our public
health aficionados
you have dr michael osterhome of course
the covet advisor to the
biden administration saying you know
what we really have to be prepared for
is the next variant so you're seeing
this trending pretty much every day on
twitter
we've already heard delta plus then
there's lambda i'm looking forward to
omega
i'm looking forward to you know all of
them zeta like
let's just go through all of them now
here's the thing
there can be a very deadly variant that
arises also there's no way you're
stopping it
just pointing this out the last delta
the delta variant itself started in
india
okay before that there was a lot of
worry about the brazilian variant you
you now have a disease in covenant 19
that's infected hundreds of millions of
people
and is particularly active right now
in tens of millions of people at a
minimum nothing you do is going to stop
the development of those variants
all you can hope is that as in the past
variants get weaker
and also that the vaccines continue to
be durable which so far they have been
you talk about how we have to worry
about the next variant and this requires
it masking endlessly
is just an argument essentially for
forever masking and forever social
distancing that's what dr michael
osterholm is doing right here
here he goes well basically the variants
that we're concerned about
uh in terms of their increased risk to
humans
have one of three characteristics or all
three
one is they're more infectious which we
know delta is substantially more
infectious even than alpha
which that by itself was more infectious
number two that they can cause more
severe illness just related to the
question you just
asked about does it cause more severe
illness for the number of people who are
infected
and number three does it have a way of
evading immune protection
is it somehow get around the vaccines or
get around
the protection you get from natural
infection and any one of those three
characteristics could make another
variant worse
and if you add all of them together it
could be worse we don't have any
evidence right now we have one that's
worse but i agree with dr fauci
that it surely is possible that one that
could be more infectious than
delta which would be hard to imagine
that being the case could actually
happen
and we have to be prepared for that okay
and how exactly would you recommend that
we're prepared for that
really i mean everyone who's getting
vaccinated is getting vaccinated
everybody who's not is not
so what exactly is your remedy and the
answer is there is no remedy
it's just lockdowns and masking all the
way down
and you get praised by the media of
course if you do this sort of stuff
even if it's completely ineffective
better for you to ruin the
school years of millions of children
than to take
rational public health measures directed
based on the evidence
this is why you have the illinois
governor j.b pritzker who has presided
by the way over a not particularly
successful covered response
talking about a new school mass mandate
because of the lower rates of
vaccination among
teens aged 20 to 7 sorry 12 to 17
because the vaccine has not yet been
approved for children
under 12. because of vaccine
because there are many people who are
reluctant across some of the districts
to adopt
the cdc's guidance effective immediately
all p12 schools and daycares in illinois
must follow the cdc guidance of
universal
masking inside regardless
of vaccine status again the evidence to
support these sorts of proposals
are skimpy at best and non-existent at
worst
jb pritzker will be championed now by
the media as a wonderful man who is
standing up to the evils of covid
i'm just going to point out to you that
illinois has a death rate
of right now 204 per 100 000 people
those are the death rates from
coronavirus as well august 4th 2021
illinois is at 204. the much maligned
florida
is currently at 184 meaning that florida
has
outperformed illinois by leaps and
bounds and is a much older state
to boot okay but that's not stopping joe
biden from going after ron desantis so
here's the thing
just like early on in the pandemic
everybody was very angry on the left at
sweden because sweden wasn't doing it
the way you were supposed to with the
giant lockdowns and the mask mandates
and everybody go in your house and stay
in your house
until the government tells you what to
do and says sweden was like okay listen
if you're vulnerable
and if you're old then we should take
precautions to help you and if not you
should probably get back to work
because sweden took that perspective
this made them the the envy of the world
there are a lot of people out there
hating on sweden even though by the way
the swedes that's a democracy they can
do exactly what they want
well florida is now the latest example
and really has been since the beginning
of the pandemic
if all you saw was the media coverage of
florida you would think florida easily
has the worst deaths per million ratio
in the united states right i mean
clearly
if you just stack up all the headlines
about ron desantis and the evils of
florida
next to the headlines about say new york
or new jersey where the governors have
been treated as though they are amazing
at this
up to and including today by the way the
governor of new jersey phil murphy who's
an idiot
was out there yelling at some
anti-baxters and people on the left were
like whoa what an amazing governor
meanwhile ron desantis is a terrible
governor
just going to point out new jersey has
the number one
worst death per million ratio in the
united states
ron desantis's death per ratio death per
million ratio of covet
in florida is approximately about 55
60 of what new jersey says new york new
jersey's at 300
and rhonda census flores at 184. so what
the media like to do
is they like to pick on desantis when
there's the surge in florida
so it is all based on timing they never
give you the overall death stats from
florida because that debunks the
argument instead
they point out when florida is having a
surge right that's a big deal when
florida has a surge that's a huge deal
and so this prompted joe biden yesterday
to go after ron desantis now again
there's another reason they're going
after desantis and that is that joe
biden is very much afraid that ron
desantis is going to be the republican
nominee for president since 24
and could just and could dismantle him
in a debate frankly
not only because joe biden is not
sentient but because desantis is
actually fairly good at this
so here was joe biden going after the
governor of my state ron desantis
yesterday
just two states florida and texas
account for
one-third of all new covet-19 cases in
the entire country
just two states look we need leadership
from everyone
if some governors aren't willing to do
the right thing to beat this pandemic
then they should allow businesses
universities
who want to do the right thing to be
able to do it
i say to these governors please help
but if you aren't going to help at least
get out of the way
the people are trying to do the right
thing oh they're trying to do the right
thing oh
joe biden what what a stellar stellar
example of a man trying to do the right
thing well ron desantis was not taking
the sitting down
he went directly back at biden which by
the way is one of the reasons he's so
popular among republicans
he went back at him just i mean just
face planted him so he did a press
conference
yesterday in which he uh in which he
said listen
mr president you seem very intense on
masking people up and locking them down
and um if you are interested in renewed
lockdowns
i will stand in your way by the way this
is a political battle that is very bad
for joe biden
joe biden right now is sinking his own
political approval rating because
americans are highly pessimistic about
the future of the virus they're
pessimistic about the ability of
government to stop it
they're pessimistic about joe biden's
presidency now
and ron desantis knows this this is not
a good battle for joe biden to pick
he picked the wrong guy to pick on here
was desantis face-planting him yesterday
if you're coming after the rights of
parents in florida
i'm standing in your way i'm not going
to let you get away with it if you're
trying to deny
kids a proper in-person education i'm
going to stand in your way
and i'm going to stand up for the kids
in florida if you're trying to restrict
people
impose mandates if you're trying to ruin
their jobs and their livelihoods in
their small business
if you are trying to lock people down
i am standing in your way and i'm
standing for the people of florida
now the problem for the left is that
they wish that desantis was some sort of
anti-vaxx advocate desantis has been
super pro vaccination
the sansa's estate trenched out the
vaccinations based on age while the cdc
was telling people not to
desantis has been pushing vaccinations
extremely hard but desantis does
recognize something that the rest of us
should also recognize
which is that for public policy purposes
this pandemic
is no longer in the hands of the
government everybody
who wants to be vaccinated has now been
vaccinated if you want to get vaccinated
tomorrow
that can be your lucky day because every
day can be your lucky day we all have
the ability to get the vaccine at this
point
which means government no longer has a
role here desantis knows this does hands
has doubled down on this he says listen
we're not going to be dr fausch's
biomedical security state that's not how
we make decisions here in the state of
florida
and so i think the question is is we can
either have a free society
or we can have a biomedical security
state and i can tell you florida
we're a free state people are going to
be free to choose to make their own
decisions about themselves about their
families
about their kids education and about
putting food on the table okay desantis
didn't stop there
he pointed out that it's kind of weird
that joe biden is singling out florida
because florida ranks middle of the pack
in terms of deaths per million
and is the second oldest state in the
union after the great state of maine
which has
approximately seven old people in a
moose here is desantis saying
weird that joe biden would single out
florida joe biden is taken
to himself to try to single out florida
over covid this is a guy who ran for
president saying he was going to quote
shut down the virus
and what has he done he's imported more
virus from around the world by having a
wide open southern border
you have hundreds of thousands of people
pouring across
every month and it's not just from
mexico in fact it's rarely from mexico
you have over a hundred different
countries where people are pouring
through
not only are they letting them through
they're then farming them
out all across our communities across
this country
okay and he is exactly right about that
sansa's continuing along those lines he
says listen why don't you do your job
you're saying i'm not doing my job how
about you do your job like secure the
southern border instead of shipping
people with covid
into communities like mcallen texas why
don't you do your job
why don't you get this border secure and
until you do that
i don't want to hear a blip about covid
from you
thank you okay correct correct okay so
there's a reason why biden is running a
little bit scared
of of ron desantis at this point and
there's again a reason
why the biden administration is
targeting one governor above all the
other governors and that is because
desantis is the
governor of a swing state he's pretty
popular down here and he's been doing
a very very good job okay by the way the
very and points to desantis for for
standing strong on this stuff there are
other governors who are not like asa
hutchinson who's the republican governor
of arkansas
he had signed into law a bill banning
mass mandates
and now he says i wish i hadn't signed
that bill he's trying to bet
he's trying to backtrack that i don't
know for the love of the media or
something because here is the record on
mass mandates there is
no evidence that mask mandates are
successful
anywhere there's no correlative evidence
that demonstrates that mass mandates
cause people to mask up
in vast numbers as opposed to just virus
spreading in particular community
there's no evidence that mass mandates
have any real impact on human behavior
generally speaking because there's no
way to enforce them nonetheless here's
aids hutchinson trying to please the
democrats which of course is always a
fool's errand
well i signed it at the time because our
cases were at a very low point
i knew that it would be overridden by
the legislature if i didn't sign it
and i was not supportive of uh i'd
already
eliminated our statewide mass mandate
and so
you know i signed it for those reasons
that our cases are at a low point
everything has changed now
and yes in hindsight i wish that had not
become law
but it is the law and the only chance we
have is either to amend it or
for the courts to say that it has an
unconstitutional
foundation okay even scientists like
scott gottlieb are saying that masks
themselves when it comes to the adult
variants are not going to be the key
method of killing the the viruses spread
the key method of killing the virus
virus's spread
is going to be vaccination that's it by
the way
we've already hit the downslope of r for
delta
in states including arkansas apparently
as well as missouri
and soon we'll hit it in florida it'll
be fun to watch how it just disappears
from the media's radar how the media
will have been look at this terrible
search in florida it's so terrible it's
the end of the world and then we'll hit
the downside of the surge
and we'll move on and then in the winter
there will be a surge in new york
because it will get cold outside and
people go indoors and the media will
just
kind of ignore it and the the truth is
that the the the the lack of
understanding of basic human behavior
by the media is pretty astonishing and
the willingness to believe the myth
that the only people who are not
vaccinating at this point are kooky fox
news watchers
that's also really weird we'll get to
that in just one second because there is
one it's the clip of the day okay it is
from a boston mayor
her name is kim janey okay she's the
black interim mayor
because she took the place of somebody
who joined the the
biden administration and this black
democratic mayor of boston
is saying things about vaccine mandates
that are significantly wilder than
anything republicans are saying but i
don't see joe biden attacking her
and there's a reason for that and it's
openly political we'll get to that in
just one moment first
even when the world is falling apart
there is one thing that is in your
control
your beard and the products you use to
ensure that you've got a beard to rival
the likes of matt walsh
and jeremy boring and the rest of the
very beardy crew
at the daily wear if you're currently
growing or maintaining a beard you need
a beard
supply beard supplies products reduce
any itchiness and keep your beard
looking full
not only will they tame your beard
they're all natural and handcrafted here
in the united states of america because
you need your beard to be as american as
humanly possible for a limited time
beard supply is offering a buy one get
one free on their beard oils it ends
this week
go to beardsupply.com buy two beard oils
for the price of one
mix and match different scents or stock
up on a classic this is your last chance
to take advantage of this
special offer so head on over to
beardsupply.com
buy one oil get a second one free that's
go check them out right now
beardsupply.com
buy one oil get a second one free and
make that beard more magnificent than it
has ever been
with beardsupply.com go check them out
right now alrighty in just one second
we'll get to the
attack on vaccine mandates of the day
from a black
democratic mayor first you may have
noticed that things are getting pretty
ugly out there you have a book called
the authoritarian moment
about the rise of authoritarianism in
the united states left-wing
authoritarianism
in our institutions the takeover of all
of these institutions by the woke
uh and uh you may have noticed that that
the president of the united states is
openly saying that he's gonna do
unconstitutional stuff and the media are
cheering him
yeah i think it's a good time for you to
go get a copy of my book the
authoritarian moment it is number three
on the new york times bestseller list
this week
is number four on the amazon bestseller
list this week tens of thousands of
people have already bought it become
one of them it is time to learn how to
say no to tyrannical government
the authoritarian moment is now
available at amazon barnes and noble or
any other major bookseller go get your
copy right now leave a five star review
let others know that this book
is worth their time i always appreciate
that you buy it
also you may have noticed that the world
has gone mad american politicians are
acting increasingly authoritarian
well that's why it's never been more
important that we get together and talk
about it especially over
your favorite the cigars and the whiskey
backstage and that is why we are giving
away a trip for two
to come hang with us your favorite daily
wire host backstage here at our national
studio you can meet us all tour the
studios and offices
get a great swag bag of merch watch us
debate on the show live
but you're going to want to hurry
because this is your last chance so if
you're not a member yet head on over to
dailywire.com
backstage enter code backstage in at
checkout for 25 percent off your
membership and
get automatically entered to win one of
the coolest trips you will ever take
it's something you're going to remind
your children
and grandchildren of hundreds of years
from now when they write your life story
this will be a seminal moment in your
life story we are taking our last entry
tomorrow
friday august 6th this is really your
last chance to come hang with us
backstage so again
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
with code backstage get 25
off your membership and a chance to win
the ultimate backstage
experience i'm also going to recommend
one more thing today and that is that
you check out our newest
podcast morning wire it's been topping
the apple and spotify charts
since its recent release it's the only
daily news podcast that values your time
and the truth and while we're working
overtime to bring you the news you need
to know
we need your help to keep the facts
trending toward number one
so subscribe right now to morningwire on
apple spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts leave a five star review if you
like what you hear
brought to you by daily wire editor and
chief john bickley and co-host georgia
hal
morning wire will wake you up with the
latest developments in politics sports
culture and education all with a heavy
emphasis on the facts in 15
bite-sized minutes perfect for your
daily commute again
subscribe to morning wire on apple
podcast spotify and everywhere you
listen to podcasts so you don't miss a
beat
and if you like what you hear leave a
five-star review tell the podcast
platforms conservative news belongs
at number one on the charts you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
now you may notice that joe biden is
attacking ron desantis and greg abbott
and only
republican governors but what's weird is
that there are some democrats who are
pretty darned hesitant about things like
vaccine
mandates and and vaccine passports one
of those people
is the current mayor of boston a woman
named kim jady
she of course took over for the former
mayor marty walsh who left to become
secretary of labor
under joe biden she is currently running
for a full term
and kim janey she got pretty damn spicy
about all of this she got very very
angry i think rightly so about some of
the vaccine mandate stuff but she's
using language
that is very i mean when i say spicy i'm
talking about like she
took out like the the full package of
pepper and just tossed it
right on top of this here was kim cheney
the mayor of boston a hardcore democrat
there's a long history in this country
of people needing to show their papers
during slavery post slavery
as recent as you know what the immigrant
population has to go through
here we heard trump with the birth
certificate
nonsense here we want to make sure that
we are not doing anything
that would further create a barrier for
residents
okay and this is my favorite she says
anything that would further create a
barrier
for residents of boston or
disproportionately impact
bipoc communities bipod communities are
people of color okay so
she's now comparing vaccine passports to
slavery
and that that's what she's doing and
she's also saying that it
disproportionately impacts black people
that's kind of an amazing statement i
don't see joe biden going after her
right where is joe biden why isn't he
saying you need to get out of the way
either do the right thing or get out of
the way weird he's not taking on the
democrat
who's saying this i noticed also he has
not
i've noticed very little from the biden
administration about how do you convince
the disproportionate number of black
people who have not gotten vaccinated to
get vaccinated
and it's good i've said before i think
it's going to be a lot of fun to watch
bill de blasio
and now they're talking about doing this
in l.a by the way watch bill de blasio
try to ban some 70 of black people from
being able to go to restaurants
because that's what the vaccine passport
does 70 of black people
in new york city are not vaccinated by
far
the highest rate of non-vaccination
among any demographic group
in new york city so what happens when
suddenly black people can't go to
restaurants and can't go to gyms and
can't go to indoor spaces can't go to a
yankee game
how does he think that's going to work
out for him the entire democratic party
has forwarded the lie that disparate
impact
means that discrimination has taken
place so i could easily say something
like well you know what
if it's a neutral rule then whether it
disproportionately impacts one group of
people or not really
makes no difference it's a neutral rule
right but democrats don't have that foot
to stand on they can't say that
if democrats were to acknowledge that
personal behavior is responsible for its
own consequences
then they couldn't make the case that
they are constantly making about
america's evil racism
which they are can which they're always
blaming for every disparity in american
life
from wealth and income inequality to
single motherhood
to drug abuse they're constantly
attempting
to chalk up every disparity in american
life to systemic racism so how do they
run away from this one exactly
that's what i find so amusing here when
kim janey says that any policy that
disproportionately impacts bipod
communities
must of course be discriminatory and
she's talking about vaccine passports
get ready gang because that is going to
be the left line and it's going to be
fun to watch the left eat the left
of course the left could just take
multiple positions at the same time
they're fond of doing that
in fact that's exactly what aoc the
estimable irrepressible
so fresh so face aoc has been doing so
uh yesterday she was caught on tape
uh doing a photo op with her face mask
on and then immediately after the
cameras were off she's like yeah this
mask is stupid and i'm not wearing it
anymore it was kind of funny
there she is she's fine she's not
wearing the mask she puts on the mask
just for the photo three one two three
just just like she uh she is constantly
talking about income inequality but then
she parks her tesla illegally outside
the whole foods
she is the rules never apply to the
special people
as we say over and over and over again
okay well i did
want to bring you one piece of news that
i personally found
highly amusing and i wanted to give you
an update on so
yesterday axios reported that politico's
newsroom is now attempting to unionize
within with the news guild
okay so this means that politico's staff
apparently are now joining like the new
york times
and a bunch of other left-wing
publications in attempting to unionize
which is usually really bad for business
okay usually it means that you are
artificially increasing the labor rate
it means that you are artificially
increasing the the benefits
it means that you're costing the company
more money which generally tends to
remove from the bottom line
and crimp growth right this is why so
many private sector unions have
basically dismantled at this point
but apparently the political staffers
are apparently very very into forming a
union
here is the part that i loved the most
okay this is pretty spectacular
according to axios organizers are
currently trying to gather signatures
for a statement to present to management
in the coming weeks
asking for recognition of the union the
union drives covers
the union drive covers employees of
politico and ene news
and energy and environment trade
publication political acquired last year
according to a political staffer
politico added about 65 reporters and
editors via that deal
there are about 375 editorial staffers
of both politico
and e and e total so what drove all of
this
according to axios sources say several
factors have pushed employees to seek
union support when bartering with
management
including the company's handling of
internal pushback against having daily
wire editor
ben shapiro guest host politico's
flagship newsletter product playbook
earlier this year remember earlier this
year they asked me to write their
playbook
right it's like a kind of obscure
insider washington dc newsletter
i wrote it like don lemon had written it
the same week they just had basically
a rotation of various political actors
writing the political playbook i wrote
it
200 staffers got on the phone with the
bosses apparently this provided the
impetus for unionization of politico and
let me just say i couldn't be happier
i couldn't be happier last year the
national labor relations board accused
me of being too anti-union and tried to
file some sort of lawsuit against me
that ended up going away pretty quickly
but
let me just say i'm very pro this union
in fact i'm happy to be
the politico employee union rep i'm like
the samuel gompers
of politico and i take my rightful
mantle here
as the union leader over at politico i'm
amused
that that my very presence in politico
allowed
for the development of the possibility
of the union over there
man all i do is apparently just like
accidentally destroy left-wing
institutions
oh i do pretty spectacular stuff
alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content coming up
soon the matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pablo wydowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show
morning wire on today's episode we speak
to dr marty mccary about whether mask
and vaccine mandates are backed up by
the evidence
backlash builds against andrew cuomo and
an olympic athlete flees belarus
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire